.
NOBODY WAS WHIPPED.
NOW BACK TO YOU.
>> Charles: THANKS, BILL.
I WANT TO GET TO THE NATIONAL
BORDER PATROL COUNCIL PRESIDENT,
BRANDON JUDD.
A LOT TO GET INTO.
FIRST, THIS REPORT FROM CBP ON
THE AGENTS BEING CLEARED OF
WHIPPING MIGRANTS.
JUST TO REMIND THE AUDIENCE AND
BILL ALLUDED TO IT, PRESIDENT
BIDEN SAID IT WAS HORRIBLE TO
SEE, TO TREAT PEOPLE LIKE THEY
DID, HORSES NEARLY RUNNING THEM
OVER.
PEOPLE BEING STRAPPED.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
I PROMISE YOU, THOSE PEOPLE WILL
PAY.
AT THE TIME EVEN THE
PHOTOGRAPHER SAID IT WASN'T
TRUE.
THAT WAS THE NARRATIVE THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE WENT WITH.
>> YEAH, PEOPLE CAN MAKE
MISTAKES.
PRESIDENT BIDEN CAN MAKE
IT'S EXCUSABLE IF HE COMES BACK
AND CLARIFIES.
IF HE WOULD APOLOGIZED TO THE
AGENTS BEFORE THE EVIDENCE WAS
OUT, THAT WOULD BE ONE THING.
THIS PRESIDENT REFUSES TO TAKE
ANY RESPONSIBILITY FOR ANYTHING
THAT HE DOES, INCLUDING FALSE
STATEMENTS THAT RUIN AGENTS
CAREERS.
THESE AGENTS HAD BEEN ON
ADMINISTRATIVE DUTY THE PAST TEN
MONTHS.
THEIR CAREERS ARE BASICALLY OVER
AND RUINED BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES FAILED TO
LET AN INVESTIGATION TAKE PLACE.
HE FAILED TO REASON TO THE
EVIDENCE.
HE ONLY PANDERED TO ACTIVISTS
AND THAT'S WHY THE AGENTS ARE
SUFFERING.
>> Charles: IT HURT ME AS A
BLACK MAN BECAUSE EVERY TIME
PRESIDENT BIDEN OPENING HIS
MOUTH, HE'S TELLING BLACK
AMERICANS THAT NOBODY LIKES YOU,
YOU'RE UNDER THREAT.
THAT GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS ARE
OUT TO HARM YOU.
IF YOU'RE A BLACK KID AND YOU
LISTEN TO THE PRESIDENT, YOU
THINK THESE PEOPLE ARE CHASING
YOU DOWN AND HITTING YOU WITH A
WHIP.
THEY DELIBERATELY DO THIS.
IT'S MORE THAN THE BORDER.
THEY STOKE FEAR AND DIVIDE US AS
A NATION.
IT'S THE MOST DESPICABLE THING
POSSIBLE FOR THE PERSON IN THE
WHITE HOUSE TO DO.
DO YOU EXPECT AN APOLOGY?
>> NO, HE WON'T APOLOGIZE.
WHAT MAKES IT DIFFICULT, IT'S
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME AND MY
FELLOW AGENTS TO PUT ON UNIFORMS
AND GO OUT AND DO THE JOB.
WE KNOW WE'RE GOING TO BE
SCRUTINIZED.
WE KNOW WE HAVE THE TARGET ON
OUR BACK.
WE KNOW THAT ANYTHING THAT WE DO
THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T LIKE,
WE'LL BE IN TROUBLE FOR.
THESE PEOPLE THAT DID THE
INVESTIGATION, THEY'RE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH EMPLOYEES.
THEY FALL UNDER THE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT RUINED THOSE THREE
AGENTS LIVES.
HE RUINED THOSE AGENT LIVES.
HE COULD HAVE RUIN THE
INVESTIGATORS LIVES IF THEY
DIDN'T FIND THAT THEY DID
SOMETHING WRONG.
WHEN YOU LOOK TO COMMISSIONER
MAGNUS SAY THAT HE HAS
CONFIDENCE IN THE INVESTIGATION,
OF COURSE HE'S GOING TO SAY
THAT.
HEX A POLITICAL APPOINTEE.
IF HE DOESN'T SAY THAT, THE
PRESIDENT COULD REMOVE HIM.
THE PRESIDENT COULD HAVE ENSURED
THE OPR INVESTIGATORS, IF THEY
DIDN'T FIND SOME SORT OF WRONG
DOING, HE COULD ENSURE THEIR
CAREERS WOULD HAVE BEEN RUINED
AS WELL.
>> Charles: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
GOVERNOR ABBOTT'S ORDER, THE NEW
ORDER TO RETURN MIGRANTS.
HOW IS THAT WORKING OUT?
YOU THINK THAT IS THE RIGHT
MOVE?
>> IT IS THE RIGHT MOVE.
IT'S UP TO THE GOVERNOR TO
DECIDE WHAT HE CAN DO UNDER HIS
AUTHORITY.
THE COURTS HAVE TO STEP IN AND
TELL HIM THAT HE CAN'T.
HE HAS TO DEVELOP A PLAN AND
PROGRAM FIRST AND DECIDE FOR
HIMSELF WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
LEGAL.
I'M GLAD THAT HE'S STEPPING UP.
I'M GLAD THAT HE'S DOING WHAT IS
HE'S SECURING THE BORDER THAT